- I know my last business idea
didn't quite work out, but.
- What was it again?
- Beard oil for dogs.
- Right.
- I call it Groomio and
it's a guaranteed success.
Turns out there wasn't much market demand
and the FDA called it unsafe and cruel.
But my new idea is certain to take off.
- Okay, let's hear it.
- Coffee made from root vegetables.
I'm calling it Beet Street Cafe.
I've got everything planned out.
I just need one person to give
me $200,000 to get started.
- And where are you going
to find this person?
- Oh, don't worry.
They'll turnip.
(upbeat music)
(coins clanking)
Whether you're looking
to purchase inventory,
expand your staff or
up your marketing game,
business loans can provide
the necessary cash flow.
It's a pretty simple setup.
You borrow a lump sum of money up front
and then pay it back
over time, with interest.
Loans that are backed
by the US Small Business Administration
are the holy grail.
Low rates, small down payments
and long repayment terms
are the norm,
a winning combo for cash
strapped entrepreneurs.
- But qualifying for an SBA
loan isn't always so simple.
For starters, you'll
probably have to demonstrate
that your business has been
around for a couple years
and has a track record
of reliable revenue.
- Wait, but doesn't
being a new business mean
that it's, you know, new?
- Yeah, it's kind of a catch 22.
You have to be profitable
to qualify for funding,
but most startups need
funding to be profitable.
If you're just at the starting line
of launching a new business,
a regular term loan might be a better fit.
Interest rates are typically
higher than SBA loans
and your window to pay off your loan
will probably be smaller,
but it isn't as hard to qualify.
If that doesn't work out,
you can look into a business credit card
to unlock immediate financing,
but be ready to use your
personal credit to get approved.
- That's a super important detail.
Whether you're applying
for a business loan
or line of credit, lenders
want some reassurance
that you aren't going to
take their money and run.
A strong credit score
essentially tells them
that you're good for it.
Some lenders might even
require you put up collateral,
like your home or your car,
so that you've got some skin in the game.
Tread lightly.
If you default on your payments,
the repo man could come
knocking on your door.
- Anyone who's ever watched an episode
of Shark Tank knows the setup.
An entrepreneur pitches their idea
to a group of thirsty investors
who will hopefully bite
at the chance to get a
piece of their business.
The winning shark then receives a slice
of equity in exchange for funding.
This gives them an ownership
stake in the company.
If the business does well,
they'll get a cut of the action.
- It can be a win-win on both sides,
but it's inherently risky for investors.
If the business goes under,
the money they put in will
go down with the ship.
It goes without saying
that you'll wanna craft
a killer business plan
and fine tune your sales pitch
before your pitch meeting.
The question then comes
down to finding investors.
(doorbell ringing)
- There are a few ways to go about it.
One option is to hit up friends
and family who want to get
in on your new business.
But if you're denied a loan from the bank
of mom and dad, you can look
to an angel investor for guidance.
These are individual investors
who usually have deep pockets
and a wealth of business experience.
Most will come in and play an active role
in growing the company,
from doling out capital to
weighing in with business advice.
- Venture capital is
cut from the same cloth,
but works a little differently.
Instead of a single investor,
you're working with a
VC firm or fund manager
that's looking to drop large chunks
of cash into viable startups.
The entrepreneur plants the seeds
with a great idea and solid business plan.
Then VC investors water the
crops and watch them grow.
- Crowdfunding can be
another way to pump cash
into your new business.
You can go about it by trading
ownership shares for capital,
seeking good, old
fashioned donations online,
or swapping products or
services in exchange for cash.
Crowdfunding is pretty legit
and generates a lot of cash each year.
- This might sound kind of obvious,
but you can also use your own money
to bring your business idea to life.
Cash savings make for a
quick source of capital,
but be careful not to completely
drain your emergency fund.
If your car breaks down or
your roof springs a leak,
you'll need to crack open that
piggy bank to cover the bill.
What we're getting at
here is that you always
wanna leave a little cushion
in your savings account.
- A personal loan might make
for a better financing option.
They are structured like business loans
and can unlock a one time pile of cash
that you can use for whatever
business expenses you want.
One downside is that interest
rates are usually way steeper.
You're also co-mingling
your business finances
with your personal credit,
which will affect your credit
score for better or worse.
- We've really only scratched
the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to business financing.
Successfully funding your
idea really comes down
to your unique needs.
A small team operation that
doesn't have much overhead,
probably won't need as much
cash as someone who's say,
opening a storefront business.
- Your ownership stake
plays a big role too.
While some entrepreneurs
are happy to give up equity
to get their hands on
some much needed capital,
others may be reluctant
to invite more cooks
into the kitchen.
- This is all to say that
every business is different,
but understanding your financing options
is the first piece of the puzzle.
And if anyone out there wants
to fund Beet Street Cafe,
that would be totally rad.
- ish.
- [Both] And that's our 2 cents.
- Thanks to our patrons
for keeping Two Cents financially healthy.
Click the link in the description
to become a Two Cents patron.
- Before you start
rooting around for money,
make sure running a
business is something you
really carrot all for.
Check out our video,
"Do you really wanna be your own boss?"
(upbeat music)